you've got a good yes and uh going for
yourself there lindsay you do a lot of
improv or anything because you're very
funny and quick and you you have that
natural kind of you you add to the
comedic flow really nicely that's like
the most amazing thing to hear from you
so
you know
why did you just bomb it
like comedy and stand up is my favorite
thing and i've actually just started
writing to do
um some stand up it's funny because
people say i've always wanted to try
stand up and it's like i
believe that it's something that i'm
going to work at to do i
and honestly my favorite thing to do in
the world is laugh like it's so much fun
to have fun
laughter is like the best in the world
like let me pee my pants my muscles down
there aren't working very well anyway
and i'm just like
jesus christ what happened they just
make some notes apparently
i'm i have a stressed pelvis
what
yeah
and i have zero kids so this has been an
interesting thing to learn wow i'm gonna
google that everyone's seen their pelvic
floor physiotherapist
i didn't think we were going here at all
no i'm i'm stunned but i'm also not
surprised yeah yeah that's just what
happens here
uh i complimented you on your comedic
spill
skills and you went right to the spills
and you went right to your weak pelvic
floor yeah uh and um here we are but uh
yeah
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't if you've
had if you've had kids you should look
it up so now like no stressed pelvis is
a is a red flag google search yeah well
it's stressful before
okay
does this happen to guys too
i don't know not the pelvic floor part
but guys can experience uh how do you i
was gonna say incompetence i have
relaxed pelvis yes i have been diagnosed
with incompetence
you know exactly what you're talking
about
it's like yeah i'm 100 out of 100 if
they made a depends for incompetence
i would be their biggest spokesperson i
would depend on them yes i think you
have a good compass you have an amazing
compass so i think you'll see so
i mean you're my north star though right
oh i don't know about that compass
oh your compass just went screwy
you just you just drove into a tree yeah
yeah well lindsay it's first of all
happy birthday yes
oh my goodness thank you yeah you uh
you're you really are a funny nice uh
positive person and it's lovely to talk
to you and
i just uh you know if you have a
question for me i'm happy to answer it
oh yeah okay my question for you conan
um one is uh do you have a meditation
practice of your own and the follow-up
would be would you consider trying
floating at all well
i'll answer the second one first i will
definitely consider floating and i think
we should put a mic i do too and i think
we're going to do this this is yeah this
is going to happen uh so that's going to
happen soon and and thanks to you
lindsay for putting us on to that i will
tell you this i've had a terror i've
tried to meditate yeah it has not gone
well
um i i and i know people say you've just
got to keep at it yeah i may be
uh there was a famous
saying once
i think freud said the only people who
are immune to therapy are the irish
and yes i may be
immune
to
meditation it sounds like you're immune
to believing in yourself right now you
know just start with that like let's
let's shift that believe in yourself you
can meditate oh no you understand
lindsay i know me
i've met me
you know the way when you're supposed to
believe in people but if they've screwed
you over many many many times
that's me yeah i have i have
i have i have
written bad checks to myself so many
times
that uh all my friends agree you've got
to cut conan loose so that's where i am
i have tried meditation i've tried uh
many times and it does not come
naturally to me
but
i'm determined to crack it one day
what about
uh trying have you tried transcendental
meditation is that where i get a word
yes yeah can i say the word over and
over again
yeah purple monkey dishwasher
um wow okay you know maybe i'll try it
maybe i'll try it i'm definitely getting
like that as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly yes that's right if our
listener is private i'm going to make a
45-minute tape of me just saying
and we'll offer that up for our
loyal viewers asmr is the hot [ __ ] right
now so i'm sure that people will buy it
do you oh my god me too dude i love it i
love the cooking videos
with the sound oh my gosh
blending yeah yeah yeah are you talking
right now like people go and they cut up
the soaps in different ways and then you
cut the soaps and it goes the sound yeah
yeah what do you what's mukbang that's
interesting i'm talking to lindsay and
you two are talking to each other
um this is the stupidest interview i can
imagine i'm literally lindsay's talking
and she's discussing like what and and
she's the focus here and in the corner
girly's like but wait what are you
talking oh oh yeah yeah sona's the focus
but like i'm just here too
she's the focus on fortnite
this is going to happen we're going to
do it okay uh my only prerequisite is
that i'm completely nude in there but
you have to be you have to be yeah you
wanted to be oh i just assumed i'd be in
like 1920s bathing suits no no
no as you put it your full don johnson
is out there you're not you don't you
can leave the one-piece unitard at home
okay you can wear that and where does
the mic go
well it's a clip-on ooh maybe up here do
one of those um bone ones no that's for
hearing britney spears one i think it
has to be a room like hanging above so
you can take your perforation you can't
if you mic me and i'm in a tank of
saline you've pretty much created a
battery you know you're yeah
yeah
you're introducing electricity
a salt water tank with a human floating
point not over not
who just performed like a really quick
risk matrices in my head you're good
wait a minute your major qualification
is that you assembled buck hunter
i'm sorry
hey i was a chemical hey man my previous
life
what have you done i was a chemical
engineer and i assembled buck hunter now
get in the tank and hold on to this
electric record
uh lindsay happy birthday really nice to
meet you
um you're a great person i hope we meet
in person someday that'd be cool yeah it
would be super cool this is such a
remarkable experience thank you so much
i'm a huge fan of you and the show and
sona and normally like i cannot believe
that this is happening i should treat
your stress pelvis to a floatation
session i'm about
you stop talking about her stressed
pelvis sorry
none of your concerns
yeah i think the minute you heard it
smoke bomb prepared once once gourley
mentioned stress pelvis for the ninth
time it's time for you to log out yeah
turn around three times